time now for an intermittent segment we
call the friendzone we invite one of our
actual friends from Fox on to the show
when he's not serving as Fox's chief
national correspondent and Henry writes
and reads books he's already written one
about Jackie Robinson and he's here
tonight exclusively to reveal the theme
of his next book Tucker
I've been waiting I'm so excited about
this I'm waiting to do this hang on
actually okay well actually we have a
Fox News Alert I'm gonna hold on before
you get the breaking news in his
Tucker's birthday and this was an
elaborate hoax I'm not writing a new
book but I'm bringing in a couple of our
good friends to help celebrate well I
was not aware of this at all they wanted
to tell stories about is kind of a robe
well this is so nice okay your cake is
covered in wax this is gonna happen
thank you well that's amazing it's a bit
you actually have the right number on
there oh Emily that's oh my gosh look at
all just I'm trying to take this in good
humor I can't believe you did this
is this actually on TV 50 is good for a
fine Bordeaux you're just getting into
your prime now I can say that at the age
of 50
you've got everything you need for your
career going forward because you have
all your hair and as far as I can tell
most of your teeth it's mostly real and
half of your wet it's mostly really and
actually my wits are in great decline
I'm not as fast as I used to be whether
we had literally no idea this was
happening and I said to our beloved
Emily Lin whatever you do I don't want
you to acknowledge my birthday in any
way old actually tomorrow because it's
so depressing and I've spent all day
brooding about mortality you until I
talked to Britt who said well can I talk
about the impact you've had all around
the world yeah all rather well yes you
may so I was in Scottsdale yesterday for
this Fox station some we had a great
time but over a thousand of our viewers
came out and they were waiting out in
the heat so I went out there with John
Finley one of our bosses and we were
handing out water we were taking
pictures shaking hands and Eric went
ball The Washington Post was there and
he wanted to do a story on it and you
I'm famous with this mug I don't know if
we can and this is the best part people
in the crowd let me hold it up
they recognized Eric wimple from the mug
from the mug they were like you're that
guy on Tucker's mug that's all he's
accomplished and here's the things they
were like you look better in person
and so do every said it here's the story
yeah that's pretty rough it was not his
best moment I'm glad we commemorated it
I don't know what making Eric whemple
famous maybe that's not much of a legacy
actually he made me feel a little sad
you still have time Tucker that's just
what you've not even I've known you for
20 something years yes many years doing
events with you all the and Tucker is
literally one of the people who never
ages he looks the same
you've never aged so you don't don't
worry the rep time and you've had that
since what yes many years well I used to
have rep bowties yeah we got you a
birthday cake flavored vape you know
vaping pens so totally given yeah Oh
shucks well for my 50th birthday I got
off the Nicorette count and that's what
you really I really did he had to quit
it after after 36 years do that I did it
one month and three days ago and these
do every now showing your tobacco
tobacco of any kind long has this been
going on for what for 36 years
oh no I'm talking about it's going on
absences going on for one month in three
days how do you feel I feel honestly
like the contents of my head have been
emptied I feel noticed I feel like an
untethered balloon actually floating
above looking down you remember some
time not too many months years ago when
you were at CNN and there was a there
was the the embarrassment I bet the
phone number I knew and you came over to
the you came over to the bureau to try
to get it the only person who remembers
that this was unit 2001 or two I was
hosting a show at CNN and as a joke I
gave out the Fox News Bureau number on
there yes on the air and Fox News which
always hits harder
gave up my whole phone number Oh hon
it's there yes and so I stormed over to
the Fox News Bureau
by the way I've worked at Fox News for
10 years today many years ago and I 17
and I storm over there and I ran into
James Rosen I said I want to get in
there and tell him what I think and I
saw Brit who I lived across the street
from and George Tenet as a kid and
really respected and Purdue becomes a
talker I don't think you can win this
one maybe it's just give it a rest and
then I walked back to the CNN Bureau
with my tail between my legs we've said
that you said at the time that that you
were afraid of Roger Ailes I was afraid
of Roger Ailes yes who ended up hiring
you guys who I wound up loving yeah it's
really a great and wise man tucker is
one of the well we have a lot of great
people at fox who support what women are
trying to do an advancement of young
careers but tucker is actually one of
the people Britney or another okay ed
you're fine okay I'm all right but but
Tucker and I and we do the primetime
thing and so we hit hard and we're also
targets there are few people I'd rather
be in a foxhole with taking the shots
then Tucker Carlson because we're just
like if it's like incomings like Bing
Bing Bing Bing it and we deal with it
every day and it's just that you've been
a great help to me and a great
inspiration and I want to say I want to
thank thank you even though we don't we
don't hang outs like we don't hang out
Tucker in the hallways like Laura
Ingraham and then he just walked by I'm
like hey that's Tucker that he's
delighted that he recognized you I'm
deep in space that's that but we spend a
lot of time texting we do we talk we
talk a lot offline and you've been it
you've been a great help and it's such a
great addition to this and this network
well thank you
would you I just have to ask in closing
Brit Hume would you have any advice for
a man entering this stage of one night
this is a I'm asking you this question
cold so if you have no good advice it's
okay I all I can say is longevity is
tough in this business yes hair and
teeth are important go to the dentist
right brushing the comb brush and comb I
got other dentists right keep your
health don't get fat yeah
that's a tough one and your and there's
a tough one it is a time go to the gym
yeah nicotine getting birthday cake
there you go and keep on doing what
you're doing
climb back on the Stairmaster tomorrow
how long do you I'm not gonna ask you
any age related question thank you yeah
well how long do you have to go till 50
uh two more after this Colossus which
would you offer any advice a man on the
on the lower end of it looking up I like
the teeth idea I didn't think about that
because think about the hair but the
teeth I think princeps Willy right and
don't eat that cake Tucker don't become
one of those old people who just talks
about their ailments because if you sit
around the table and you start getting
into that conversational happy warrior
and I think that came across well I am a
happy person and by the way if I had a
goiter I would never mention it we were
gonna be pretending I would pretend it
wasn't even there are gonna be smug and
pomposity to thank you guys I appreciate
it thank you very much we're out of time
that was that was weird and great